let's bring in our panel Jonathan Swan
national political reporter for Axios
Abie Schneider - associate editor at
RealClearPolitics and host of No Labels
radio on Sirius XM and former White
House press secretary Ari Fleischer all
right let me start with you you've been
through a few of these state of the
union's sometimes can be you know
laundry lists but sometimes they can
have an overall message it seems like
this message from the excerpts and what
the president said today is about unity
and coming together and that is exactly
what Donald Trump needs to preach
tonight at the State of the Union you
know this is gonna be his biggest
audience of his presidency you're gonna
have tens of millions 30 40 sometimes 50
million people watching and so it's an
unfiltered chance to show people who you
are and what's in your heart and it's
also the form in which the president
delivers that speech it's made for
presidents and there's going to be
applause for the things he says which
also sends a nice signal to people at
home when they hear the ratification the
reinforcement of what he's saying
through applause everything favorable
for the president but his weakness is
his unfavorable ratings he still is
underwater and the State of the Union
like this especially if it is unifying
as the White House tells us it will be
has a chance to fix that to move the
numbers in Donald Trump's direction it's
his best chance to move those numbers it
is a be the one time when all of
government comes together whether they
are together on the same sheet of music
on agenda but they are all in the same
room and the president makes his pitch
yeah I think it's unfortunate that the
bunch of Democrats lawmakers are saying
that they want to boycott the event this
is an event that everyone should be at
whether they are members of the Co a
cool branch in the Congress or obviously
in the president's administration but it
is an opportunity for Donald Trump to
tell a great story on the economy stock
market gains the benefits of
deregulation obviously the success of
passing tax reform different than last
year's joint address to Congress on
February 28th he's trying to sort of
portray himself as you know portray his
accomplishments and I think it's a night
to take a victory lap on those topics we
are told he's going to extend an olive
branch to Democrats on infrastructure
and immigration I'm sure he will talk
a tough talk on border security and
those things he you know he campaigned
on but I think that it is an opportunity
for him to say we've done what we can on
the Republican side and it's time to
reach across the aisle and I want to be
productive in light of those numbers
already talked about and the headwinds
Republicans face going into the midterms
it is the best posture for him to take
you know Jonathan speaking of numbers
you know I referenced this poll Fox poll
for last night this is the president's
job performance and as you split down
the groups you have Republicans 86%
Trump voters true Trump supporters 92%
Democrats at 11 percent an independence
at 38 percent there's part of this his
overall approval by the way in this poll
is 45% it's it's interesting even under
all of the attack that he's taken that
he's he's still managed to get approval
that's in many polls you know in the mid
40s or upper 40s well Brett one of the
stories that hasn't really broken
through and and I think people are still
missing is yes the tax bill was deeply
unpopular when it was released when they
passed it but if the numbers have been
going in the right direction it's been
moving and it could keep moving by the
way when we keep seeing companies
announce you know bonuses jobs people
starting to get a feel in their paycheck
which is one of the big things that the
president wanted to kick in before the
midterm election so I'm hearing people I
had lunch today with a very prominent
Democrat who suggested to me that they
were less than easy about the notion
that they're gonna take the house so I'm
starting to hear some some doubt into
people's voices about this supposed
foregone conclusion that Republicans are
going to lose the house this year which
is an amazing turnabout if you think
about if what we've heard and
conventional wisdom over the past few
weeks re you have five five different
Democratic responses tonight five
different responses to this State of the
Union address I think it's fair to say
if you had this five different responses
to a Democratic president by the GOP
that there would be a lot of stories
about you know civil war different
messages they're not unified no
leadership you don't see a lot of those
stories today no of course you don't
because that's not the way most coverage
works but this is a precursor Brett this
is a precursor to the 2019 2020
Democratic upcoming primary where you're
going to have 15 20 maybe even 25
Democrats running and every single one
of them is going to try to get to the
left of one another until they fall off
the face of the earth because the earth
is flat if you follow that far left you
just can't have that many candidates
trying to slice up a political ideology
it's gonna be a race to the left you'll
start to see that tonight in the
response to Donald Trump maybe
obviously there are uphill challenges
for this president one of them is this
investigation we don't know we don't
know but but reaching across the aisle
is pretty tough if Democrats are at
about 11% and lawmakers don't seem like
they're budging to work with this
president at least not yet but Brett you
know it's it's in the outreach if it's
genuine and he's not tweeting at them
and calling them losers and he actually
brings them into meetings and does what
he's done a few times having you know
them at the table at the White House if
he actually stays at the table with them
and sort of shames them into the process
even the ones who don't want to budge
and stays in negotiations with them
about his position on a fix for daca and
the dreamers doesn't change his mind the
minute they leave the meeting they
actually will end up in a relationship
that can bear fruit in an infrastructure
package so I think that the next couple
of weeks will be consequential he
certainly doesn't want a government
shutdown his highest approval ratings
ever on anything were him striking a
deal with truck and Nancy much to the
consternation of his own party leaders
even though it wasn't even really a
substantive deal it what it was his
finest moment if you look at polling and
I know he likes polling so I think
tonight is the opportunity and so is
this month and quickly Jonathan I mean
he believes I get the sense this
administration believes that they are in
a pretty good position negotiating wise
after what they saw was a win
the last shutdown showdown I think they
were surprised actually I think that the
that was surprised that Schumer played
it the way he did and capitulated after
three days so yes agree but there is a
nervousness about the next step and
ultimately I think most of the people in
there who've paid attention to politics
for the last you know decades know that
the party that controls the House the
Senate and the presidency probably won't
get off completely
free if this falls apart in the
negotiations yeah exactly